[Music]
look what I become
I gotta tell you guys are funny in the
in the chat come back and forth with the
nicknames about the podcast starting on
time anyways today we're starting
without Michael Saylor and Adam because
they're stuck in traffic coming up from
Miami apparently there's a bunch of
accidents but Tom it's you and I until
they come in at any point they can come
in good morning so when they do come in
here's what we want to talk about we
want to talk about the fact that Michael
Sayler and microstrategy spent 179
million dollars
on bitcoin last quarter uh Michael
Saylor says banking crisis is driving
Bitcoin adoption we'll talk about
binance we'll talk about uh worse than
2008 how ethereum co-founder says
Bitcoin and crypto not braced for a 540
billion dollar crisis we'll talk about
we'll talk about crypto price warning
China Biden and the FED could be about
to destroy all value of Bitcoin this is
a Forbes story and then Biden is pushing
a huge tax on crypto it could backfire
spectacularly Washington examiner but
before those guys come in Tom two or two
stories Rob found here that I really
like first one Warren Buffett formula
for Success one good decision every five
years what what a what a great way to
manage decision making process right
this is a guy that's been added with his
company for 58 years and he credits
roughly 12 decisions so here we go
Warren Buffett's annual Reddit letter to
shareholders reflects that in the last
58 years of investing and identifies
only a dozen good decisions they've made
averaging one every five years as a
source of Berkshire Hathaways three
million seven hundred and eighty four
thousand four hundred and sixty four
percent return over that period Buffett
believes that fewer than 20 decisions
made a difference for him and it's not
about getting every decision right but
getting the important decisions anomaly
right his successful investment strategy
involved investing in insensibly
priced opportunities at big companies
with honest people competitive advantage
and understandable enduring and
mouth-watering economics and partnering
with the right people such as Charlie
Munger and Ajit Jane Tom what do you
have to say about this well I think if
you look back at it
um this kind of goes to uh and and folks
could Google this and the S P 500 the
longer you look at it the harder it is
to be right you've been in financial
services for a long time the longer you
look at it like five years ten years 15
years you make a little chart sure the
harder the s p is to be and if you look
deeper into that you can find these
stories that tell you that there were 30
days in the history of the s p that if
you miss those 30 days
um you you really miss something like
the 2009 had two days where there was
like these five percent bounce
turnarounds remember that yep you know
2009 everybody said what's going on in
2009 I'll send boing up five five
percent one day another five percent one
day and all of a sudden your temper for
the year and so what what uh Warren
Buffett is coming back and basically
saying is hey
um we've made 12 good decisions and we
could probably uh you're saying that let
me do what I just found according to
Hartford fund if you missed the Market's
10 best days
over the last 30 years this is S P 500
your returns would be cut in half there
it is that's it and that's why the S P
500 Index like a cash index held for a
long time is usually a good idea and
that's why a lot of the life insurance
products like PHP sold you built this
monstrous Life Insurance Agency on a
nationwide basis Pat and a lot of those
iul index Universal lives were tied to s
p indexes so it showed that something
that's stable like life insurance so
back to Buffett you asked me about
Buffett I think if we decode this we're
going to find Buffett is saying like the
day I invested it the day I went all in
on coke the day Coca-Cola the day I went
all in on Geico I'd be willing to bet
that his 12 big decisions is probably
those days because remember there were
days where Buffett decided to go all in
on some companies that have come back
for him in spectacular fashion so it
sounds to me like he's saying the same
thing like the story you just just read
and what the common knowledge among the
investment Community has been about
long-term Buy and Hold on the S P 500
don't miss those days and by the way Tom
if if there are certain decisions like
when you think about creating wealth
right
um too many people put this pressure on
themselves I believe of getting it right
every single time right it's a different
story with Investments and and you know
things you invest into specifically than
it is with you know other things you do
in your life with Investments if you get
one thing right you know that could make
you a household name you could have
failed in 18 different businesses none
of them worked out and then all of a
sudden boom one thing you get right you
sell it for 50 million you sell it for a
couple hundred million you sell it four
billion dollars now everybody goes back
and talks about that one success story
right so it it Buffett's story validates
and hopefully encourages a lot of people
to be a little bit more patient he's
selling long-term thinking
with how to make your investment
decision I think it's a great a great uh
philosophy especially to learn from a
guy like him I heard a statement and
it's really short and it's this if
you're going to invest remember it's a
cornfield not a sports book you go in a
sports book oh maybe I'll bet on this
Laker game yeah and then 10 minutes 20
minutes later there's another game
starting maybe I'll bet on this one so
if you're bouncing in and out if you get
a Robin Hood account you're bouncing in
and out that's a recipe for you know you
never beat the sports book you may get a
one big hit once in a while maybe the
super professional gamblers get it but
the average guy going into a sports book
around the Super Bowl or March Madness
they never get it we see that whereas
you treat it like a cornfield what do
you do once a year you harvest some corn
and you have patience in between
agree very good lesson there from
Buffett here's another one new cars once
part of the American dream now Out Of
Reach for many this is a Washington Post
story low income earners earners in
America are being priced out of new cars
Market while high earners are buying
more than ever before spending on new
cars by the lowest 20 percent of earners
reach its lowest and 11 years while
spending by the top 20 reached its
highest on the record according to 2021
consumer expenditure survey so by the
way what they're saying is the rich are
getting richer and the poor getting
poorer which I'll have my point on this
one here in a minute the average price
of a new car in U.S hit forty eight
thousand eight dollars in March up 30
percent from March of 2020 and the
demand for cheaper models have been
shrinking for years the problem
preventing many Americans from buying
new cars are twofold one Rising interest
rates have made car loans far more
expensive with the average monthly
payment reaching 7 30 in April of 2022nd
the a supply of Cheaper cars have been
shrinking as manufacturers focus on more
expensive high-end models the global
chip shortage caused by the pandemic has
forced automakers to ration their
components reserving them from more
profitable Vehicles Tom what are your
thoughts on this I got some thoughts but
I want to hear from you first
um well this is this is what's you know
when um when money is no longer free and
you can no longer get you know that
two-year lease with those teaser rates
um you know and let's face it a lot of
people are aspirational about their cars
what I mean by that is they run to the
payment that they think they can afford
to get the glitzier vehicle
very few people are thinking like you
know Dave Ramsey and other people that
says hey be very practical about your
personal budget in the car you get think
about safety think about what you can
get but right now what I see I see this
um a friend of mine turns in a Mercedes
GL SUV now remember this is we're not
talking a G wagon just Mercedes GL and
it had it on a three-year lease in the
name of his company he goes into the
dealer and he says what's my buyout on
this because the vehicles are expensive
I'm just going to buy the vehicle
um and says give me the number and he
said we'll give you two numbers here's
the bio number that's in your contract
and here's fifteen thousand dollars he
said what's the fifteen thousand dollars
we will buy that vehicle from you right
now for fifteen thousand dollars and he
said yeah but if I walk back in the door
to get another new one on the lease
what's that going to be and so the
economics didn't add up and so he paid
about forty eight thousand dollars
bought out the Mercedes GL had very low
miles on it
um after three years and then it's like
oh my gosh the high-end cars the demand
is there to the point that that was a
local Mercedes dealership going to do
that yeah first person can't do that
though no the average person can't do
that but that's the point they're making
about what's happening in the high end
now in the on the low end
what's what's happening is the American
public has been a payment based public
right the average person is payment
based oh I can afford that payment so I
can get something a little financing
everything
and they do they do the payment to
Lifestyle I can afford that payment so I
want to step up so I can get the
lifestyle out of it and what's happening
is the interest rates are up and the
little mini lease and the cheap lease
two year three years the party's over
and now they're having to go in and look
at wow that's forty eight thousand
dollars plus 10 and everything so it's
53 out the door and I'll put you know
five grand down if they've got that so
forty five thousand over five years
Bingo 700 bucks you know and it's um and
there's the pinch point and I think the
pinch point is the reality and the
average American doesn't want to go in
and get the base model you know
Toyota Corolla that's not what they want
you don't have a choice still but but
here's what I will tell you here's what
I will tell you to the people who talk
about the rich get rich and the poor get
poor and they complain about it you have
to realize every one of these things
that you're seeing happen that's
destroying Middle America folks
the the concept of well you see you know
what what about the middle American
Income you know what they can't afford a
car like this well let's talk about why
what's causing this what is causing this
to destroy Middle America that they
can't afford something like this because
the guys in the middle that are working
their tails off for 22 bucks an hour 28
bucks an hour trying to do what they can
for their kids their families you know
they're sitting there saying I cannot
get a new car I I can't get a new car I
have to go finance a used one and it's
backfiring on me bad policies have
consequences many policies seem Noble
today I'm reading a book it's called
toxic uh charity I don't know if you've
read this book toxic charity
and I'm going through it and he starts
off the book Tom by saying the following
he says I have to read this to you he
says uh uh uh man I gotta find this to
tell you there it is okay he says over a
trillion dollars of Charity was given to
Africa do you know what percentage of
the money that was given to Africa was
actually used and went to the people 15
85 of the trillion dollars that was
given to Africa to help everybody was
like we're gonna help Africa We are the
world we are the children
this what a great cause let's keep
raising money
dude only 150 billion out of the
trillion dollars went to the people what
happened to the 85 trillion dollars and
then he continues talks about never do
for the poor what they're capable of
doing for themselves this is a guy
that's been doing charity for 40 years
and he says I'm here to tell you more
churches and Charities are destroying
communities coming from a good place but
they're hurting them so I'm listening to
this recording has nothing to do with
politics all he's doing is calling our
churches and he's calling our Charities
and I said I'm like what is this guy's
point you know look at the subtitle
right there Tom how the church hurts
those they help and how to reverse it
this is a guy that's a Christian guy
that's been raising money for 40 years
and he's saying this the more you read
the book the premise is you think you're
helping people by giving them money
you're actually not you're hurting these
people so when these guys were talking
about let's send money to people
let's do another trillion dollars let's
do another trillion dollars let's do two
let's take care of these people let's do
what's Andrew Yang's plan about a
thousand dollars every month being given
to people what did he call that uh Ubi
Universal basic income let's send people
money this is we can afford it we can
afford it we can affordable because they
need a living wage wait who determines
what the living wage is and the
government starts turning the dial on
what a living you know what a living
wage should be a Ford pickup so I'm
going to turn the dial up oh is it
election year we're giving everybody a
truck now
they send them the money and then all of
a sudden you know what they did with all
this money they sent to help the poor
you know what they really helped they're
rich
because what they don't realize Poor
People's problems is their habits listen
when I was broke and if it was fifty
dollars in my bank account all I knew
what to do with the fifty dollars was
what to spend it if I had five hundred
dollars guys let's go out it's on me if
I had four hundred dollars I had such a
poor broke mentality with money until
that changed nothing was going to change
so rather than trying to help these
folks with the money you sent to them
that they don't know what to do with it
first thing we got to do is teach them
about how money works but nobody wants
to teach people how money works it's all
the other stuff that people want to talk
about this book psycho cybernetics this
guy Tom who becomes a a
surgeon he does cosmetic surgery for 15
20 years they ask and they said why did
you become a cosmetic surgeon he says
because I wanted to make people happy
and he says every time I would do
surgery this this book still by the way
35 40 million copies he said every time
we do surgery I would look at their
faces they were so happy and I'm like
man I made somebody happy today breast
augmentation or face or whatever he was
doing he says you know what happened six
months later they went back to the same
depressed miserable people they were he
says I realize after doing this for 15
20 years you can make people happy from
the inside from the outside you can only
make them happy from the inside so he
went and got away from that business and
started becoming a psychologist working
with people on the mindset writes a book
called psycho cybernetic cells 35
million copies what we're trying to
solve all these poor people's problems
from the outset by sending money to them
why don't we work from the brain why
don't we work from teaching them
mentally on how to deal with their
finances and other areas of their lives
so the next time it comes to vote for
sending more free money to people just
remember this the more free money you
send to the market all you're doing is
making the rich richer and the rich keep
getting richer and the poor keep getting
being poor because your policies that
sound Noble on the outside actually
destroys Middle America Tom I I
completely agree and Pat you know where
my charitable heart is but you also know
that my charitable heart changed about
12 years ago because I was I was part of
American mega churches and you know I
was a person attending there but then I
would look around and say no wait a
minute you know where can the church
have the highest impact during a
disaster Karina
there's not people down there it you
know it didn't rain four foot of water
and then you know uh Lake Pontchartrain
flood because of their habits it was
because of Hurricane Katrina and you can
go down and provide relief and you can
meet certain basic needs you and I both
know of a church in um in Dallas where
we used to go and they operated a
medical clinic for people who did not
have medical insurance but they didn't
come in there to get a gift they came in
there to get you know an antibiotic when
they had bronchitis and they had no you
know medical insurance or it was a
single mom that had inadequate insurance
that is where Charities can stand in the
Gap where 90 of that dollar is providing
a bridge on something that is not
lifestyle related and what you're
talking about there are there are
organizations out there and they hate
them remember at the auto industry
thought of JD Power the first time they
were putting out those Awards they were
like who is this SOB that's doing this
and they hated it because the lists were
real and they couldn't just put million
dollar marketing around the list sorry
dude your SUV is not reliable and
therefore you don't get the JD Power
quality award now people you know that
kind of forced them what's happening in
Charities Pat is there are organizations
out there that are looking at the two
taxes tax number one you give a dollar
to a charity how much of that dollar
gets used up by the local Administration
the people in America collecting the
dollar operating the office and if it's
more than about eight to twelve percent
that's an inefficient charity the second
is how much of the dollars so now let's
just say ten percent now we have 90
cents over 90 cents we're going to feed
the children in Africa okay how much
gets to them and what was it doing
and then you find out that there's a
government tax in there that the
government actually snatched 50 percent
of that or that you do the most terrible
thing is you buy commodity like flour
and things like this that's a tradable
commodity guess who takes it half of it
gets taken by the by the government and
the government then sells it so the
average American doesn't know I gave a
dollar wait a minute a dime went to
these guys Administration in the U.S and
then the rest got to Africa and that's
exactly what he's talking about this guy
let me let me tell you what he says he's
so right about toxic charity here's what
he talks about in the book he says he
says uh lupton's oath offers six basic
guidelines never do for the poor what
they can do for themselves two limit One
Way giving to emergencies yes empower
the poor through employment lending and
investing using grants sparingly to
reinforce reinforce achievements for
subordinate self-interest to the needs
of those being served five listen
closely to those you seek to help and in
particular listen to what is not said
be apparently felt and above them all Do
no harm and then
he talks about the five cycle okay this
this is very powerful the ever
descending life cycle of Charity one-way
charity give once and you listen give
once and you elicit appreciation give
twice and you create anticipation you're
gonna give it to me again I anticipate
three times and you create expectation
where's my money
give four times and it becomes
entitlement give five times and you
establish dependency okay very
interesting when you think about this
give once you illicit appreciation give
twice you create anticipation give three
times you create expectation give four
times it becomes entitlement and give
five times you establish dependency well
you know what this means and I'm gonna
make I'm not gonna make enemies here but
I'm gonna upset some people so
those of you that are Christian churches
preaching from the pulpit about how what
is welfare done look how welfare's
messed up our city they've created the
dependency of these people look in the
mirror because some of the stuff you're
doing is causing the same thing
yeah and it's happening I mean you you
you you know and by the way I learned
this the hard way in my third year in
business I was 24 25 years old 26 years
old I put on my own sales office and I
had a good friend of mine who was one of
my sales guys and he starts making money
but he starts dating this girl and he
buys her like a three four five thousand
dollar Rank and he takes her on this you
know place and he's spending all this
money and he says I can't afford to pay
rent this month and he says but you make
money off me so give me a break for one
month I said no problem give me a break
for a second month no problem give me a
break for third month no problem you
know what happened by the fourth month
by the fourth month it was expected that
he doesn't need to pay rent by the
eighth month when I ask for rent of the
previous eight months that I was paying
myself he became an enemy relationship
changed from that day on so as much as
you're thinking you're doing good you're
hurting them when you go out of your way
by the way we got the great Michael
sailor in the house Justin I-95 is
broken free
they let Adam and Michael Saylor in
what's up Adam Michael Saylor how are
you sir how you doing doing good awesome
good to see you man good timing we got
90 minutes to get as much we can out of
your brain as possible Michael they say
great minds think alike so you and I
arrive at the same time how bad was it
but it must have been pretty bad it was
very bad it was very it was horrible in
Miami and even worse in Fort Lauderdale
what do you think Michael I think people
aren't working from home anymore
there we go and by the way at least not
in Florida well said Michael well said
although it is the first it is the first
week of May and it's supposed to be now
that over the last three weeks from
Easter in May 1st the snowbirds were
supposed to have driven North so we used
to see these Canadian license plates
these New York and Pennsylvania license
plates I've seen fewer of them and you
would think that uh we would have a
little traffic break as the snowbirds
migrate back North
well thank you for that update I was
very happy about that weather update
guys update weather's going to be okay
that's what Tom is trying to say Michael
uh I got a handful of things I want to
go with you my goal is to try to get it
done in 90 minutes there's this guy in
uh this street he lives on uh what's the
street called Pennsylvania and he lives
in the city he lives in this city DC and
he's a pretty important guy they just
call him Joe but he's a pretty important
guy and there's a few things that's uh
formulating that I kind of want to run
by this is a Forbes article okay crypto
price warning China Biden and the FED
could be about to this could be about to
destroy all value of Bitcoin okay so
let's see if this is just a propaganda
if there's any credibility to this story
with cbdc Bitcoin price has doubled
since November reaching around 30 000
per Bitcoin despite criticism and
negative declarations
Texas Senator Ted Cruz has warned that
Central Bank digital currencies
inspired by Bitcoin and digital
currencies could destroy all value of
Bitcoin and undermine its anonymity and
decentralization China is currently
leading the way with the digital one
which some see as giving governments
unprecedented power to surveil and
control citizens Crews introduced
legislation to prevent the creation of a
digital dollar saying the US government
has no authority to unilaterally
establish a central bank currency he
added that those who want a cbdc dislike
cash because it is not subjected to
centralized control and constant
surveillance which is a key feature of
digital currencies despite its concerns
about cbdc Crews remains incredibly
bullish on bitcoin calling it clearly
the alpha in the current crypto sphere
are you just as concerned about this as
Senator Cruz's
um I you know every time a politician
wants to ban guns there's an explosion
in demand to buy guns
right and so uh so talk about cbdc's
really is a marketing event that causes
everyone to think about a world where
they don't own their own money
and that makes them think well what kind
of money could I acquire that I would
own and the most censorship resistant
monetary Network in the world is Bitcoin
so interest in cbdc's is just going to
drive more feverish interest in Bitcoin
it's uh it's actually
driving awareness and Bitcoin is growing
as people become more aware that they
need something which is
non-sovereign store of value nation
state resistant
so and if there's hyperinflation people
want Bitcoin that's why they are
thinking about Bitcoin in Argentina or
in Nigeria or anywhere in Africa right
now if there's moderate inflation people
that are sensitive to it will go for
Bitcoin and then the people that think
the inflation will go away will look at
it as an oddity
um but you know money is uh it's a store
of value a unit of account a medium of
exchange and then there's a fourth
characteristic that we don't talk about
it's the it's the thing that's not said
it's a system of control
so certain monies are easier to control
than others for example you know we we
talk about gold as money but you ever
try to carry
um a gold bar through an airport very
heavy uh you know try it next time
um you know they won't let you through
right in fact if you tried to carry a
hundred thousand dollars of gold to an
airport Not only would you not get
through but the assumption would be
you're a criminal you stole the gold and
they would just take it and keep it
without a court order
now
try to carry a hundred thousand hours of
cash through the airport you ever try
that put it in a bag and just you can
put it in a bag and as you're walking
through the TSA check or the uh the
X-ray machine just nonchalantly say to
the officer yeah I'm carrying a hundred
thousand dollars of money onto the
airplane
right you won't get through now not only
will you not get through they'll just
take your money
right they'll just take it and the
Assumption will be you stole it okay so
cash is a unit control now put a hundred
thousand dollars in a bank and try to
wire it uh to someone or just take it
out and they're going to ask you why
tell them it's none of their business
uh try to send it to someone uh
privately tell them you just want to
send it to a numbered Swiss bank account
right see how that works that won't work
right uh that's a system of control
um a couple of stable coins have been
getting shut down paxos is busd got a
Wells notice they got shut down and
custodia tried to launch a bank and they
wanted to issue Avid avids were digital
dollars and they were digital dollars
that were going to circulate on crypto
Networks
and uh and The Regulators denied that
banking license and it's about a 70 page
denial letter very articulate and I read
it all I read thousands I read all of
the crypto uh legislation and all of the
crypto uh litigation so if you dig into
that denial letter which is very well
written uh and articulate what is very
clear is that is is the regulator say
we're not going to allow the bank to
form because we don't want to issue
someone we don't want someone to issue
digital dollars that will circulate on
cryptonetworks non-kyc well you know
evading our money law our anti-money
laundering rules our anti-terrorism
roles or or know your customer roles
so it's clear that The Regulators reject
with prejudice the idea that you can
circulate large sums of dollars without
reporting that now that's a political
football right because a lot of people
in this country think that you should
own your own money and you should have
Financial privacy and you want to be
able to do what you want with your money
there's another group of people that
don't agree right Ted Cruz is on the
side of Freedom you ought to own your
own money now it turns out that um if
your money's in a bank you're not going
to be able to circulate it freely it's
controlled
um and on the other hand Bitcoin is the
one network you can't control you know
Ted Cruz's famous line is I like Bitcoin
for the same reason the Chinese don't
like it they can't control it nobody can
control Bitcoin so if you're if you're
insecure about being able to own your
own money do you own it and can you
actually use it without asking
somebody's permission
then the solution Is Not Gold it's not
silver coins it's not stacks of cash
it's not money in a bank in the U.S it's
certainly not money in a bank in Lebanon
Argentina anywhere in Africa those Banks
won't let you they won't let you take
your money out of the bank go look at
Nigeria forty two dollars a day that's
how much you can take out of the bank
they're keeping your money so the one
network that you have that gives you a
decent chance of owning your own money
and then being able to spend it the way
you want is Bitcoin so I'm not worried
about Bitcoin I do think that there'll
be a massive political fight over cbdc's
there's a technical challenge our
government doesn't know how to issue a
cbdc we don't know how to issue digital
currency the people that are issuing
digital dollars are the cryptocurrency
people right you know paxos knows how to
issue a digital dollar right and The
Regulators Cinema Wells notice saying
shut down
so the private Market knows how to issue
digital dollars the government doesn't
the EU doesn't the feds don't and so
even if they wanted to they can't
technically right now without somebody
else's help but as long as Congress is
split right it seems to me quite clear
there's a large faction uh by the way on
the Democratic and the Republican side I
mean Robert F Kennedy I don't think's in
favor of a cbdc nor is Ron DeSantis in
favor of a cbdc so there are a lot of
free thinking politicians in both
parties that are adamantly against
having a system of control where the
government can decide how you you know
it used to be ten thousand dollars was
the cutoff of the report right it used
to be you had to report when you wired
ten thousand dollars and that was back
when ten thousand dollars was worth
something right it used to be I think it
dates back what 30 50 years or something
so it used to be ten thousand dollars
was a lot of money and then they kept
the the ten thousand dollar limit and uh
inflation creeped up and pretty soon ten
thousand dollars is is not nearly so
much money and what we're seeing is a
encroachment of that where now people
are starting to lobby for the government
to get a report on everything spent more
than six hundred dollars and they lower
the number well who's supportive of that
I mean right now if you look at Federal
Reserve here's a tweet from Ron DeSantis
you were talking about April 7 the
Federal Reserve has made no decision on
issuing a central bank digital currency
and would not do so without clear
support from Congress and executive
branch uh ideally in a form of a
specific authorizing law a cbdc would
not replace cash or other payment
options and then the census at the
topsis it is not merely ideal that major
changes in policy receive specific
authorization from Congress it is
constitutionally required unaccountable
institutions cannot impose a cbdc on
Americans they will tell cbdc won't be
abused but we are wise enough to know
better this wolf comes as a wolf Mike
Michael the question I'm asking is this
whole thing with 600
forget about the politicians that want
it we understand why they would want it
you can control and see what people are
doing what what average voter wants to
vote for this who who the average
American that would say I'm okay with
this I I'm sure the overwhelming
majority of the population is adamantly
against it and I would say a decent
majority of politicians are against it
but there is a French Wing that wants to
impose control over everybody and they
don't trust anybody and and you know
heck at some point they would probably
like to see how you spend 50 bucks and
uh and that's that's the control freaks
in uh in the political sphere
uh you know politicians have shown
themselves quite capable of interfering
in your Private Affairs and and the last
three years have shown anything they've
shown that people can come up with some
justification to tell you how many
people can sit at your dinner table on
Thanksgiving right and and so there'll
be some of them I I don't think that
politically it's going to fly in the
near term and and the next two to four
years I don't see consensus at the
political level to impose a cbdc but I
think so I think it's it's like that
persistent Boogeyman where people say oh
it's coming and the result is
is uh more interest in the antidote to
it so I I don't think it's bad for
Bitcoin I think it's good for Bitcoin I
do think we ought to be concerned about
money being used as a system of control
is very disturbing yeah I think you you
bring up an interesting point there and
Rob I just flipped you something can you
grab that
um speaking of systems of control I want
you to look at this picture of uh the
two diplomats from India and Russia and
I think you know what I'm talking about
um it went down in the last 24 hours I
just sent you the uh the link to it Rob
take a look at that the Russian guys on
the left the Indian guys here Russia has
got billions of dollars trapped in India
that is in rupees and India is saying
you can't move them but if you want to
use them to pay for labor to build
things we're happy to do things what do
you need Bill and so this is a system of
control here this is two governments
together and India look at the posture
of the guy from India and look at the
posture of the guy from Russia
um so when we talk about systems of
control this goes all the way up to the
way governments control each other this
is India sitting on billions of dollars
it won't let Russia take back India
bully and Russia what would you have
thought that would happen
that just doesn't make any sense but
good for them good for the Indians I
have a question for Michael just on the
heels of basically what Pat read about
the DeSantis
um you know there's a story here I think
it's
sb7054 it's a question basically
regarding Florida we're here in Miami we
you know we dealt with the traffic
DeSantis the the CFO of Florida's Jimmy
Petronas he had some very harsh words uh
on cbdc's he called it government
surveillance he said it could lead to
financial slavery and political tyranny
so I you said that if they were going to
have some
um agenda to push through cbdc's they
would have to essentially have some sort
of public-private partnership right the
government's not going to do it on on
their own who would lead that charge and
what would they how would they sell that
to the people is it Gary Gensler of the
SEC in partnership with certain Congress
people like walk me through how it would
even happen and get approved via
Congress well I don't I mean to be clear
I don't expect it to happen I I don't
think uh that there is consensus in the
Democratic party or the Republican party
to implement a cbdc I don't think they
know how to do it I think there's
resistance to it
um I I think that what's going on right
now is there's a regulatory Crackdown on
crypto and so what what what is
happening is the administration is is
cracking down on crypto exchanges
it's cracking down on crypto securities
it's cracking down on some of the crypto
tokens and is cracking down on crypto
currencies and by currency I mean a
stable coin like a dollar circulating
and I think that that's creating quite a
lot of Sound and Fury and friction and
anxiety and the industry I think uh I I
think it'll continue
there is no coherent digital asset
framework that's been offered by any
regulator
there isn't any coherent digital assets
framework offered by any legislator
we're nowhere near that like there's not
a bill we're debating that if it gets
voted on we'll solve the problem there
is no bill okay and so the you know the
talk about cbdc's uh gets people you
know
quite spun up rightfully so but I think
the story here is cbdc's are going to be
a non-starter in the Free World and even
in the place that's closest to is China
I suppose
and uh and so I I really think that
it's uh it's a it's a Chinese concept
and I don't really think in the Free
World we want to be like the Chinese and
and I think ultimately uh both sides of
the aisle will agree on that they won't
agree on other things they won't they
they won't agree on private money like
for example uh probably the Republicans
uh and the conservatives would be in
favor of private companies issuing
digital currency and letting it
circulate and uh and on the other side
of the aisle they're a bit more
conservative and they you know they
would say well we only want Banks
to issue currency that report to us on
every material transaction but none of
the banks were able to issue a stable
coin either Signature Bank was unable to
issue a stable coin silvergate Bank was
on issue unable to issue a stable coin
and custodia wanted to be an FDIC
approved bank they were unable to issue
a stable coin and uh and when you ask
those banking Executives they said well
the regulars wouldn't let us so so you
sound very confident though with saying
that you're confident about what
confident about The Regulators won't let
you issue a stable coin confident about
the fact that you know both sides are
going to agree on uh not wanting to do
anything with cbdc I mean you're talking
about a direction uh we're going where
over regulation is a popular thing
censorship is being sold as a no that
makes sense I understand what they're
doing they should be silencing that
person he shouldn't be saying anything
to the point where a guy named Elon Musk
who was on track for being a
trillionaire if he would have just
driven Tesla he decides to go out there
and take money and buy a non-profit
organization at the time that he called
it a organization called Twitter right
and this story comes out Supreme Court
to decide if IRS can secretly obtain
bank records okay this is CPA practice
advisor again this is not Congress this
is Supreme Court to decide if IRS can
secretly obtain bank records uh they're
uh set to the side uh Paul Sally versus
Iris whatever the IRS uh whether the IRS
can obtain bank records from taxpayers
relatives without notice to help the
agency tax collection agencies tax
collection efforts and his decision is
expected early this summer the case
raises questions about taxpayer privacy
and IRS Authority amid the agency's 80
billion dollar on funding over the next
decade and I can continue in this case
Remo Porcelli owed more than two million
dollars in taxes to the IRS and the
agency issued summons uh to his wife's
bank and two other Banks where Paul
Sally's Law Firm had accounts without
notifying his wife or firmed that the
IRS was trying to obtain the banking
information his wife
and the law firm argued that the IRS
should have should have to notify them
if they're going to send a summons for
their information for the banks the
point here is they're more and more and
more figuring out ways to control the
decisions people are making and the way
they sell it is in the following way
saying look
you to the average person do you want to
see these guys that are money laundering
through Bitcoin do you know what's
happening with all the pedophilia the
fear of all the things that Bitcoin and
crypto is used for this is one way for
us to prevent from illegal purchase of
weapons or money you know all money
laundering all the this is why we need a
cbdc because we can catch the criminals
easier if we have that and to the
average person who's only got six
thousand dollars in the bank and it's
got a regular job let's just say it's a
regular person says you know what that
does make sense these rich people have
been laundering money for such a long
time and it's about time we find out
what they're doing and a cbdc is
something we should do
being too confident kind of gives those
guys strength because they can play
their manipulative games until
eventually one day you're waking up
saying now we do have cbdc well I
mean I I agree with you if you're a
voter you ought to not it should be an
acid test I don't think anybody should
vote for a politician in favor of a cbdc
I mean it's this is the struggle uh you
know control versus Freedom that's as
old as time right in every society and
you know and the human in the history of
the human race every society there's
always people that want to impose
control on the people and there's
another group that wants Freedom I've
been I've been reading conceived in
Liberty which is Mary rothbard's history
of the American colonies before the
Revolutionary War
and it's hundreds of chapters Non-Stop
struggle someone wants to control a
colony they want to tell you what to
think they want to tell you you know
what you know who God is they want to
Define religion they want to impose
taxes they want to seize your property
they want to tax your property they want
to impose monopolies and then there's
another group fighting for freedom and
and it was going on for hundreds of
years before the Revolutionary War
I mean there were monopolies in New York
on who could bake you know they that
there were tariffs on using the Hudson
River to go up and down the river there
were monopolies on who could trade with
the Indians they would give you land
they would steal your land they would
tax the land people wouldn't pay the tax
there were rebellions it's hundreds and
hundreds of struggles so it's been going
on before the Revolution it's going on
in every country in the world
today it's certainly going on and and if
you have any political power I think the
best way to use it is to support those
that trust people are in favor of
freedom because there's there tends to
be or seems to be this never-ending
tendency of governmental organizations
to get stronger and as they get stronger
they raise taxes they funnel the taxes
into the police state and the control
State and pretty soon it's illegal to
bake bread it's illegal to row up a
river it's illegal to cross the river
it's you know if you have land you have
to pay tax if you pay tax it has to
double
if it you know the taxes were used it
used to be we paid tax to pay ministers
to to to preach religious beliefs that
you disagreed with and if you you know
if you actually laughed or kissed your
wife on a Sunday they whipped you you
know and find you and STEEZ your
property because you were disrespectful
to the almighty Lord and and I I'd like
to say it was uh it was unique and a
one-time thing but it wasn't it's it's
kind of the history of humanity so it's
going on today it's it's reprehensible
and you can't see politicians that will
articulate that that message that the
people cannot be trusted and the
government needs to control everything
luckily we're in Florida where we where
we have a number of politicians that
believe differently
I'm hopeful that uh that we'll see a
backlash
to the control Tendencies and the
political sphere that have have
manifested themselves over the past few
years
and uh cbdc is just one of those
touchstones it's not the only one it
won't be the last one it wasn't the
first one
so you know there's an article that just
came out a couple days ago May 3rd
saying Michael Saylor I don't know if
you know that guy in a pretty big deal
of a guy we like them a lot Michael
Saylor says banking crisis is driving
Bitcoin adoption this is coin Edition
story and in the story your your talking
about you know you talked about this
briefly earlier as well
uh micro strategies Microsoft believes
that the Fiat and banking crisis is
driving the adoption of Bitcoin stating
that Bitcoin adoption is uh being driven
by the progressive global loss of
confidence and Fiat currencies
conventional Banking and competing
assets bitcoin's recent rally has led to
significant reduction in microstrategies
BTC impairment loss allowing the firm to
strengthen its capital structure sailor
indicated that microstrategy will
continue to accumulate Bitcoins as
investors confidence and Fiat continues
to erode stating that the real
key with Bitcoin is just to be able to
hold on to it and stomach the volatility
just to be able to hold on to the
stomach the volatility which by the way
very very hard to do just earlier we
read an article by Warren Buffett that
they asked him what's the key to success
he says it's making one big this one
great decision every five years
uh they were shown his 3.4 million
percent return in the last 50 years and
he says that's a byproduct of us making
12 great decisions to make what we've
done today it's hard to kind of make a
decision and stick to it during good and
bad times reason why I ask this question
is the following
gold on the other hand
there were certain markers you looked at
hey inflation is up you know hey
interest rates are going up hey we're
printing money hey they're printing more
money hey they're sending more money out
gold would typically there would be a
reaction to it right now that is more of
a reaction towards crypto on bitcoin
where it's no longer the reaction
towards gold why do you think that's
happened to gold
I think Gold's getting uh demonetized by
Bitcoin right now if you look at the
past three years since my microstrategy
bought 250 million dollars worth of
bitcoin in August of 2020. since that
time bitcoin's up about 140 percent uh
the s p is up about 20 percent nasdaq's
up 10 goals up one percent Silver's down
about eight percent bonds are down 18
percent conclusion right if you if you
buy debt govern government debt you're
going to be bankrupt that's why those
banks are going bankrupt all the banks
had had debt when the interest rates
went through the roof the debt traded
down and they all were technically
insolvent
um the problem with uh gold
is first of all if you have if I bought
250 million dollars worth of gold I
can't like carry it around in my pocket
I can't take self-custody of it I can't
move it anywhere I can't transfer it to
a counterparty and so that means I have
to put it in a bank there's only a
handful of banks in the world that
custody it and the banks rehypothecate
the gold so that means that um if you
wanted to sell 250 million dollars of
gold the bank will will sell your gold
if you want to buy it they'll sell you
paper and the paper gold isn't backed by
the actual gold so
Reserve banking of gold
right that's that uh you don't want to
own an asset where the bank can sell a
hundred acts more of that asset than
they own
that the whole problem with uh fiat
currency right if you look at the
history of banking it was you know
goldsmiths
you know goldsmiths have gold when gold
was money and they gave you a note so
you give me a million dollars of gold I
give you a million dollar note you trade
the notes back and forth that's your
paper money that works fine as long as a
one-to-one
but then the guy that's the Goldsmith
says holy crap I actually can give him a
million dollar note and he thinks that
I've got a million dollars of gold
backing it and now there's two million
in the system and then I give him a
million dollars and now there's three
million a system now there's three times
as much money there's one stack of gold
worth a million bucks prices go through
the roof that's inflation and eventually
you come back and you try to redeem your
paper for the stack I give you your goal
back and you try to redeem and the
Gold's gone and you try to redeem and
the Gold's gone okay I'm bankrupt oops
okay so uh when did this idea of of over
issuing paper money start
didn't start if you know when Nixon
defaulted on the gold standard he wasn't
the first he was just the most famous
right people have been defaulting on
paper money probably for thousands of
years and Nixon just made it official
yeah so so the issue is if gold is money
and it goes into a bank the bankers
issue 10x more more paper than there is
gold you have inflation eventually right
when the French tried to redeem their
their paper dollars for gold the U.S
basically closed the gold window we
defaulted on on that obligation and we
started a cycle of inflation from 1971
on it's been running 50 years now when
FTX failed it was no different the issue
was people put Bitcoin on FTX and then
Sam turned around and issued 3x as much
paper you know obligations and when
people try to withdraw the Bitcoin he
doesn't have it he fails when uh Silicon
Valley Bank failed or when when any of
these other bank fails they had certain
amount of money you know and then they
turned around and they and they invested
it and their investment was in
government securities the Securities
traded down now they were insolvent when
people try to withdraw their money they
don't actually have the money to pay
them off the banks fail so when you look
at this banking crisis what's going on
what you've got is a bunch of banks
everywhere in the world that have shaky
assets
right what what's what's really shaky
well if if you actually hold Argentine
pesos or or a Nigerian naira and then
you triple the supply of them every year
the value goes to zero right if that's
your currency base or your asset base
you're going to be insolvent when P when
people put 10 billion dollars into a
bank backed by pesos
the peso goes to zero the bank turns
around and reloans out 20 billion
dollars now there's 30 billion dollars
circulating on 10 billion dollars in the
bank when you try to withdraw the money
the bank collapses the entire economy
collapses that's going on everywhere in
the world uh it's much worse in Lebanon
or in Nigeria or in Argentina than it is
in the U.S
it's bad in the U.S uh but and it's
cracking on the seams with you know
First Republic Bank and Silicon Valley
Bank and Signature Bank and and the like
but uh what do you conclude if you're an
individual if you're just uh if you're a
company or if you're a family or if
you're an individual and you live
in Zimbabwe what would you do well you
can't you're not going to buy gold and
put in the bank the bank's just going to
seize your gold you're not even going to
buy dollars and put it in the bank the
bank is going to seize your dollars
you're not going to buy local Zimbabwe
dollars they're going to zero as you
stare at them they're going to lose
10 percent of their value a month right
they're just melting in your hand so you
got to buy something you can custody so
before Bitcoin you would have bought
bars of soap crates of toilet paper you
would have bought motorcycles you would
have bought a Humvee you would have
bought barrels of oil you would have
bought anything you would bought food
you would have bought bullets you would
have bought guns anything tangible that
you can self-custody you would have held
now after Bitcoin you now have for the
first time in human history the ability
to buy not a barrel of oil but 80 worth
of bitcoin
and you put it on your phone
and now you can go through an airport
with the Bitcoin you can't go there
through the airport with a barrel of oil
right and and you don't what's the big
the big difference the difference
between gold and Bitcoin and the reason
Bitcoin is up 140 and gold is up one
percent
is the middle class family can custody
their own Bitcoin and a wealthy person
can can either hold 10 million dollars
of Bitcoin in self-custody or if I live
in Africa I can move the 10 million
dollars of Bitcoin to Monaco Singapore
London Paris New York or Miami Beach and
that is not an option you have with your
gold it's not an option you have with
your dollars when you're an Argentine
Citizen and you actually called the bank
and say hey move my million dollars out
of Argentina and send it to Switzerland
they're like
no they have Capital controls they have
banking controls
the the people in Lebanon with millions
of dollars in Lebanese Banks they wanted
to get their money out of Lebanon it was
like well sorry your funds are frozen
why because the bank never had the
million dollars as soon as you put the
million dollars in the bank in Lebanon
they turned around and loaned it to the
government
it's gone the government spent the
million dollars you try to get the money
out
the bank closes its doors right is that
illegal no because the guy that runs the
government passed a law declaring a bank
holiday for the good of the country
saying that we can't allow you to redeem
your dollars so the bottom line is if
you're trying to use money that requires
Banks you can't trust the banks
right you certainly can't trust the
banks in Africa and South America and
most of Asia it used to be Americans
thought they could trust American Banks
now they're realizing that they can't
trust American Banks so the first order
impact of the banking crisis is people
think well maybe the money I had in the
bank's going away and so I ought to put
it in a bank in cyberspace that isn't
controlled by the government or by the
bankers and that's Bitcoin the second
order impact
is the solution to the banking crisis is
print more dollars
and if you print more dollars the actual
monetary inflation rate goes 10 percent
fifteen percent twenty percent so you
think why do you think those bonds
crashed
the you know because there are actually
claims on dollars
do you really want to hold a billion
dollars of Zimbabwe dollars
what if I offered you 10 billion
Zimbabwe dollars I mean the answer is
it's going to a nickel okay so if the
current if the paper currency keeps
crashing then you can't own anything
that's currency related you can't own a
currency derivative you need to own
something that politicians can't print
more of
okay what is oil that's land but the
problem is try calling a hundred
thousand barrels of oil from where you
are to London where you want to be
how are you going to do that
I'll give you a billion dollars of land
in central Africa and then someone takes
over with machine guns and declares that
everyone with large amounts of land now
loses it
that happened in Zimbabwe
you're going to pick up the land on your
back and carry it to France
so it's kind of it's simple if people
lose faith in the banks they lose faith
in the currency when they lose faith in
the currency they lose faith in the
government when you lose faith in the
bank the currency and the government and
someone says what do you what can you
trust
the answer is you can trust Bitcoin
because you can custody your own asset
you can run your own node and at the end
of the day even if the Chinese want to
shut it down they can't if the Russians
want to shut it down they can't if any
nation state wants to shut it down they
can't if the U.S wanted to shut it down
they can't and so everybody wants
something that they can trust that is
beyond the reach of a corrupt politician
a corrupt corporate executive or they
have to be corrupt they can just be well
meaning trying to do the right thing in
a misguided fashion and meddling with
your economic life if there's ever been
a time for you to make that argument and
make it aggressively and scream it off
the top of your lungs is right now
especially the fact that three out of
the four largest banks that ever gone
out of business in the history of
America were done in the last uh 90 days
you got wobble was the biggest which was
September of 2008 307 billion First
Republic was
212 billion that was May 1st Silicon
Valley Bank March 10 209 billion
Signature Bank March 12th 110 billion
and the next one closest one to it is
Indie Mac if you remember Indie Mac was
only a 31 Billion Auto Company back then
in 08 so
someone may be listening to this and say
oh my god oh man this guy's right maybe
maybe I would start moving my money out
of my bank as soon as possible and you
know Jamie Diamond I know these guys are
trying to get people not to take their
money out of the bank and have too many
Bank runs because if they do that and
you know some are taking the money out
of their bank and putting in the money
market is is Michael saying take my
money out and put him put it in Bitcoin
are you saying maybe taking them put in
a bigger Bank I'm a little concerned
Michael you sound smarter than me what
should I do the average person's
thinking that right now so are you
saying that
these three out of four largest bank
that went out of business that happened
last 90 day 90 days there's more to come
and things are going to get uglier than
what it's been last 90 days are you just
saying the fact that if you keep your
money in the bank at any point they can
make that decision and control your
money
is a store of value but and there are
multiple monies and they're not created
equal so let me give you the world's
worst money
the worst money in the world is like
Argentine pesos or Venezuelan Bolivars
or Zimbabwe dollars or Nigerian IR weak
money that my then the official
inflation rate in Argentina is 105
percent
but that's the official rate which is
which is that understates it the actual
inflation rate would be higher and if
the inflation rate is wanting a hundred
percent that means your money is losing
half of its value every 12 months
that means that within 10 years you have
nothing
okay uh so bad money
bad currency or bad money loses all of
its value over the course of a few years
in Venezuela you lose all your value in
36 months and Argentina and 10 to 20
years the Argentine peso was one to the
dollar 21 years ago
if you had uh if you had a million
dollars 21 years ago the Argentine peso
right now is about 480 to the dollar
so that's not a 99 loss that's a
99.8 percent loss right in how many
years 20 21 years
okay so what I'm saying is you don't
have money if you have weak currency now
let's take strong currency well the
strongest currency in the world is the
dollar that's not money you're losing 99
of your wealth over the course of 90
years in the in the US dollar maybe more
the US dollar the only difference
between the US dollar and the peso is
whereas it takes 20 years to lose your
family's fortune in the peso it takes
about 90 years to lose your family's
fortune in the dollar
right that my my house in Miami Beach
was a hundred thousand dollars in 1930
it was appraised at 46 million dollars a
few years ago
do the calculation it's on a path to be
worth 100 million dollars which means
that the US dollar will have lost
99.9 of its value over 100 years
Warren Buffett knows this Charlie Munger
knows this basically your the bottom
line there is your money in the bank
isn't money
okay so the answer is you shouldn't have
any money in a bank right you're you're
basically losing seven percent of all
your wealth every year in a good year if
it's the dollar you're losing 15 percent
of your wealth in a not good year if
it's the dollar you're absolutely losing
all your money over the course of a
decade so that's that's kind of weak
money awful money is developing World
money the Lebanese pound
the Lebanese pound got devalued I mean
you would have lost all your money in
five years if you had the pound the
strongest money and decent money okay
money was gold but not great the
strongest money in the world is Bitcoin
because Bitcoin is absolutely capped to
21 million it is global money you could
take a billion dollars of Bitcoin across
a border you can transfer it to a
counterparty and no government can
interdict that and nobody can inflate to
that and so so my my answer there would
be you can't trust any Bank
you can't yeah you certainly can't trust
a bank in Lebanon read about Lebanese
Banks you can't trust a bank in Africa
you can't trust a bank in Asia Michael
but if you call Chase their customer
service is amazing how is the customer
service with Bitcoin when you called the
1-800 number
nobody
working at the bank of Bitcoin to steal
your money
ah
right uh thanks for calling Bitcoin this
is John Doe calling I can't do nothing
for you you got to make the decision
yourself but I just want to say hi to
you but you know Bitcoin is a bank in
cyberspace run by Incorruptible software
it's going to keep your money if you
were incompetent then you're going to
suffer the consequences but let's think
about what what banking Executives in
the US do the U.S banking system is the
best in the world here's what they do
you put a hundred billion dollars into
the bank they have the deposits they
turn around the the Federal Reserve
interest rate short-term rate was Zero
and these guys went invested a hundred
billion dollars of those deposits in in
mid-dated long-dated sovereign debt that
was yielding 1.8 percent interest
the Federal Reserve took the interest by
the way would you would you loan me
money for 30 years
at three percent interest rate
like can you imagine that if the
inflation rate was eight or ten percent
would you loan money out at three
percent interest rate for the rest of
your life not in a million years okay
that's what the banking Executives in
the U.S did
at the sing at the point when when the
uh Silicon Valley Bank all of them right
pretty much all these guys not just not
just the ones that went bankrupt right
there's there's a host of banks
I I think they had what was like 800
billion dollars of unrealized losses or
something a host of banks went and
anybody that bought mid-dated or long
dated uh bonds
at the you know at the bottom of the
market when interest rates were zero
they were loaning out money Forever at
two percent interest or three percent
interest or one and a half percent
interest
and um and as soon as you redeem what
happened of course is the Fed raised
interest rates from 25 basis points
actually the rates went from zero to 500
basis points in 12 months about that's
the sharpest increase in interest rates
in in memory that in itself is
I'm not going to say what it is it's rep
you know it's just horrific terrifying
to think that any public servant would
do that but it's equally terrifying to
think that if I was your money manager
and if you had given me all your money
when interest rates were zero and I and
I said well I guess interest rates will
say zero for the next 30 Years
and so I'm going to loan it out as a
bond and lock in a price of two percent
you know you would have thought I was
crazy no there is no individual no
Corporation no rational Corporation no
economic actor that would loan money
forever for three percent interest when
inflation is running double or triple
that so the question is that who would
and answer is a bureaucrat
uh either a governmental bureaucrat
someone that is coerced by regulatory
policy where they're forced to
for example a bank can't buy Bitcoin
but a bank is almost obligated to buy
treasuries
right so the politicians create a set of
rules that strongly encourage you to do
certain things and strongly discourage
you to do other things and generally
they encourage you to do the thing which
is probably least economically viable
by the way there are probably local
local organizations and Banks and
foreign countries that own their own
local currency right like would would
you buy you know an African currency
with inflation rate at 200 percent a
year no but people do why because the
government controls or owns The Entity
and so they force that so uh just to
finish this topic before we move on
when you said all these guys that are
given you know their money for three
percent over 30 years or whatever
there's a lot of them Silicon Valley
Bank's not the only one signature's not
doing there's a lot of these guys most
of the banks remember that chart exactly
64 who was above it and then JP Morgan
was 14 at the yeah so the point is don't
trust your money in any bank that's
basically betting it on but but what's
your investment you say something like
that as a guy that's that's a
billionaire the average guy's not a
billionaire the only thing they know
what to do is walk up to the bank so
it's a different scenario you're on but
the question the question I want to ask
you is the final one are you saying
there's going to be bigger banks that
are on the line right now that we could
see popping up that they're in the same
situation because if most of them are
doing it you know Powell's not lowering
rates and they're saying he's not going
to do until December so how many how
much longer can these guys handle these
types of conditions yeah so let me just
answer two questions what do I think
will happen in the banking system and
what do I think a person should do what
I think happens to the bank and system
is all of the regional Banks you know
the small mid-sized banks are at a
massive disadvantage right now because
the government is is showing that
they're not going to bail out those
those Equity holders so there's a
there's a migration of deposits from the
small Banks to the big Banks you know I
think the you know the JP Morgan's the
Bank of Americas the the mega banks will
continue they'll be just fine they'll be
supported by the government the small
banks are going to struggle and that's
what that's what you see going on right
now if you're a depositor I mean you'll
probably get bailed out by the
government if you're a bondholder in the
bank or an equity holder the bank you
won't get bailed out right and so
there's a crisis for investors uh
whereas whereas everybody that's a
depositor doesn't want to sit around and
take the risk right I mean who wants any
anxiety
so I so I think that to the extent that
you rely on banks clearly
um the world is waking up and the U.S is
waking up and they're thinking I want to
be with big Banks I I wouldn't have my
money in a bank anywhere outside the U.S
in a weak country right you you need you
need to be in a rich strong country with
a rich Strong Bank
with regard to what individuals should
do
um I I think the The Logical answer is
for expenses if if you have expenses in
the next three months you have your
expenses in the local currency which is
the peso the Niara the whatever because
it's legally obligated for you to pay in
the local currency for the next three
years of expenses or one to three years
of expenses you put your your wealth in
these a strong the strongest world
currency in the world that's the dollar
right now but you make sure that you
have that currency either self-custed or
you have it in a bank that you trust
that's hard
find a bank if you were in Lebanon right
now can we trust you babe
you wouldn't put your money in any Bank
you would actually put it on the Bitcoin
blockchain for for any amount of money
you want to keep the rest of your life
if you if you want to give it to your
kids if you want to actually retire on
it anything that's investable asset you
would put it in Bitcoin you wouldn't put
you would put it in a in the strongest
possible world currency the global the
global money and that's Bitcoin you're
not going to get rich investing in
dollars and you'll lose all your money
if your dollars are in a weak bank and
if your Dollar's in a strong Bank you'll
just get poor slowly and you're going to
get four you're going to get poor
rapidly if your money is and not the
dollar but a weaker currency and you're
going to get completely bankrupt if you
trust a weak Bank
and so microstrategy by the way has
we're like 90 million dollars we had
four plus billion dollars worth of
bitcoin
so go figure right 98 percent
of our assets are actually in the strong
money two percent
is in the world's strongest currency in
the in a good bank and a strong and one
of the big four Banks right and uh and
that's about as much exposure as I want
to a currency you're obviously A True
True Believer when it comes to bitcoin
no doubt uh how much of it the fact that
we live in Miami and we see people
fleeing Venezuela Argentina moving their
money here getting out of Brazil getting
out of Cuba you know it's all South
America moving to Miami as well as all
around the world but how much of that
helps I guess codify your ideology on
bitcoin or you're 100 anyway and this
just sort of reaffirms everything you
believe when you see these people moving
here
you know you need this near-death
experience this mortality event before
you will open your mind to embrace a new
idea you know
um and if you live in Argentina when you
talk to argentines they say my family
has been completely bankrupted uh twice
in the past 30 years
okay so in in South America if you live
in Venezuela well they've all been
bankrupted twice in 10 to 15 years
um if you live in Brazil right now I
think the interest rates getting
approached to approaching 14 right money
is hard to come by
and if you live in Africa the Africans
live under the CFA uh Colonial Frank
where they lose half their money every
time they change currencies and it's not
convertible
and um
if you lived in in Nigeria you know you
just had you wake up one day and the
bank says you're only allowed to have 42
dollars a day
and if you live in if you live in India
that you know you wake up one day this
press release it says uh all all rupee
notes of 10 000 rupees or whatever above
are now illegal and you have to turn
them all in in the next 48 hours or else
they're null and void and someone just
invalidates the currency if you lived in
Russia in 1998 all the banks failed and
the ruble went to zero and everybody
lost everything
so I think that uh that people that live
in other jurisdictions if they've ever
been completely bankrupt or seen their
their economy completely collapse Sri
Lanka another good example when that
happens then when someone says okay well
here's a bank in cyberspace and an asset
that no one can meddle with and no one
can can corrupt or tamper with you think
well tell me more about that
but if you're um if you're a wealthy
American if you're Warren Buffett you
know we we have a very famous example a
video that's going viral on Twitter
13 year old girl says to Warren Buffett
I'm really worried about the U.S dollar
is the reserve currency of the world
we're printing lots and lots of dollars
and if we're not the reserve currency
the value of the dollar is going to
collapse we're going to have
hyperinflation what should I do Mr
Buffett
you know and I I wouldn't normally
criticize you know a
respected successful business person of
his age but he and Charlie Munger did
choose to go up on stage and answer
questions and give Financial guidance
and advice and investment advice and
they are looked up to and so you watch
Warren Buffett answer the question and
his answer is
well yeah I mean I guess the FED
inflated the money but they needed to
and uh you know it's really difficult
you know in politics of difficult
problem and yeah you're right it is a
problem and Monger will say you know the
Dollar's going to zero it's going to
zero they know it's a problem
and then he kind of meanders through it
with a with a an end advice which is
well you know I don't know but you know
America is a great country
dump out against America
but the ant but the but the the blood
curdling terrifying you know depressing
you know take away from the Clippers is
the 13 year old girl knows what the
problem is the country's full of people
that can articulate the problem and
write thousand page books on the problem
if you're rich
in America you don't have the answer
because you're too comfortable
right and so what you've got is a bunch
of of Mega billionaires that are very
successful in America but they don't
have an answer or solution to the 13
year old girl the solution to that
question was Bitcoin right and Warren
Buffett and Charlie Munger can't allow
themselves to understand that because
because they're so successful they don't
need to open their mind to and embrace a
new idea if Warren Buffett woke up
tomorrow and his bank seized all of his
assets and they were devalued to zero
and he was a pauper
and his neighbor the Uber driver was
walking around with a hundred thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin on a hardware
wallet Warren would say what is that
again explain that to me yeah what do
you mean my government my bank can't
steal all my money that's a pretty good
idea
right and and so I I think that when
you're a refugee from fleeing Iraq or
you're crossing the border
and you know and when you try to go
through an airport and a hostile regime
steals all your money and seizes all
your gold when you have to flee your
Thousand Acre or ten Thousand Acre Farm
in Africa because a hostile regime
decided it was illegal for people like
you to own land
when that happens you become a believer
in a a non-sovereign store of value
crypto asset Network which is what
Bitcoin is
the people that came to this country the
huguenots you know the the settlers the
the colonists I think they understood it
I mean they had all their all their
property C's from them from wherever
they came from and their idea was here's
a place where I can own something and
people might not steal it from me
as soon as they got here people started
trying to steal it from them again right
that's the Human Condition just slower
just slower but that's why they kept
going west it's like I gotta go west
where there's no politicians
to steal it from me
right and that and that's a pretty
powerful driver
so I think that that the conclusion is
people that are comfortable they're fat
dumb and happy in the United States are
going to continue to reject new ideas
like crypto assets like Bitcoin because
they don't have to
if I don't have to embrace a new idea
when I get to a certain age I won't and
that that is
that is as old as the it's the the
Thomas Kuhn structure of Scientific
Revolution he said
Paradigm shifts only get embraced in
times of War
or when the Old Guard dies
if you want to introduce a new idea you
need a war
s kind of work because if we're fighting
a war and I introduce an airplane and I
drop a nuclear bomb on your head then
you stop rejecting air power and you
stop rejecting Atomic weapons you
embrace the reality that yeah they do
work and maybe you need to figure it out
Wars work but absent a war people just
have to you know they just have to pass
on because they're not going to embrace
a new idea so you talked about Charlie
Munger and Charlie Munger gave the
famous rat poison speech right they
actually gave two speeches and the
second one he said no I didn't say it
was poison I said it was rat poison so
you're saying that he's in the middle of
the of the system was he disingenuous
was he dishonest or was he mistaken
if you don't
first you have to have an open mind and
say is it possible that this works
and then second you have to spend
somewhere around 10 hours to understand
it I just don't think he has an open
mind and I don't think he spent 10 hours
right I mean it's not it's not uncommon
right people in their 80s and their 90s
don't generally embrace the wonder that
is the Unreal Engine or Tick-Tock
90s right so it's I wouldn't again if
they were private citizens I don't I
don't criticize private 80 and 90 year
olds octogenarians and and the like uh
for not embracing the new cool thing
right they don't have to like this you
don't have to like drone races you know
you know my my father doesn't have to
like drone races in his 80s that's fine
uh but the point is if you're going to
tell people how to invest hundreds of
billions of dollars or trillions of
dollars and you're going to give advice
to a 13 year old about how she cannot be
poor or not or not starve to death
I I think that then you have to actually
study these things and the elephant in
the room
is everybody in the world is facing
inflation everyone in the world is
facing counterparty risk everyone
everywhere in the world we're losing
faith in governments Banks and
currencies
the solution is a bank that isn't run by
people that isn't subject to the whim of
a government
that is Incorruptible that allows you to
be your own bank
right and that is a message that's
getting out we just need to keep beating
the drum on that it is I think the most
important Economic Opportunity slash
issue slash technology of our time I got
I got a question for you a guy here
asked the question but for me uh I kind
of want to go through this and then I'll
go to this super chat
um what what percentage if I if we were
to break down the amount of content you
consume okay percentage-wise in the last
12 months okay
what percentage of your research and
reading is the market like the whole
Market what percentage is purely crypto
what percentage is politics
if you were to break that down if you
know 40 of what I consume is this 20 is
this 10 is this
I would say
something like a quarters politics and a
quarter is macro economics and uh and a
quarter is is the crypto economy and and
uh Bitcoin related things in the crypto
economy and the last 25 percent is is uh
microstrategy
business activity you know our our
Capital operations Capital Market
structures and and our strategic
initiatives so there's nothing that is
more than the other you're you're evenly
split amongst the four very interesting
how you do that I I would say I'm evenly
split amongst the four I I'm quite aware
that that my impact is at the
microstrategy level I get to decide you
know whether we're going to pay off a
205 million dollar loan or not right I
get to decide whether we're going to
issue a billion dollars of equity or not
and I get you know so I have an impact
over what microstrategy is doing as the
chairman of microstrategy and I have a
responsibility to my employees my
shareholders and the like so a lot of my
work is there and then
I have the ability to have an impact and
a need to to be engaged in the crypto
economy especially so I'm spending a lot
of time on bitcoin Bitcoin education
lightning development of Bitcoin
applications and lightning Network those
sort of things right that's where I
could have an impact and the macro
economy I study it because I want to
know what's going on with China and
Russia and interest rates and
hyperinflation in Argentina but I I
don't you know I I have uh
no belief that I'm going to be able to
control that right like I don't pretend
to be able to direct Argentine
macroeconomic policy and with regard to
politics in general
you got to pay attention to what's going
on with you know the Tucker Carlsons of
the world and you got to pay attention
to the presidential race and and the
politics the Senate and Congress and the
regulatory activities but it's above my
pay grade right I have a there's a
hundred things that are going on the
political sphere and when you say above
my period I don't have control over it
is what you mean i a
you know I don't have control over it B
my opinion is not welcomed
right
I don't have credibility right I'm not
going to express strongly held opinions
on medical policy or interest rate
policy or the like because it is
distracting and so I I think you have to
study it yeah and you and you know I
have to know where the wind is going for
example there are some countries I would
not live in right now
I'm not going to tell you which ones I'm
just not going there are some places I
would not go right so same in countries
that people you would assume are safe to
live in
why wouldn't you traditionally I'm look
there's a war going on in the Ukraine
right so yeah I mean do you pay
attention you pay attention right there
are places I wouldn't make an investment
sure there are places I would not go
there are places I would not live
right but if you look at my Twitter
profile I have laser eyes
and and the significance of laser eyes
is if you want to make progress in this
world you have to focus and Channel all
of the energy you have behind a very
very particular objective and I have one
laser-like Focus right Bitcoin is good
money right Bitcoin is good for the
world Bitcoin is is a is global Freedom
Global property rights interesting right
like
I have a hundred other opinions but if
if I actually filled my feed with here's
what I think about bicycles and here's
what I think about diets and here's what
I think about health and here's what I
think about you know labor policy and
here's what I think about states rights
and here's what I think about this
country at some point uh you just dilute
your focus
and you just you don't have that much
energy in this life well we really
brought you today to talk about what
your thoughts were on a plant-based diet
because I know you've been researching
that for a while I'm just obviously
joking with you but my question at my
point I can talk for an hour about it
but but the point is I'm not going to
change anybody else's deeply held
opinion on plant-based diets what
sources do you go to when you say you're
researching what do you read are you a
Zero Hedge guy are you a Wall Street
Journal what do you what do you read
you know I'm I'm scanning everything on
Bloomberg News I'm scanning everything
on the Wall Street Journal home page I'm
scanning the news feeds on anything
related to bitcoin
um I'm scanning uh you know the major
papers the the New York time to see what
they're thinking I'm I'm scanning
Twitter what they're thinking it's
useful to know what they print right on
the New York Times thinking like they do
a lot of so uh yeah we could go there
yeah but you don't think you could use
everything in New York Times the point
is the point is what's what's on the
front page like what is what is the
narrative on the front page what is on
the front page of the Wall Street what's
the paper that what's a paper you read
that's like not a common paper like is
there some site or in a journalist you
trust somebody that writes that you
follow an expert I don't think you could
I don't think you could in good faith
endorse any any one news Outlet in the
modern world I think I think uh you have
to scan everything and you have to
consider what statistically significant
and of course what you find and then and
the news media is oftentimes
it if 92 percent of the people are dying
of natural causes
95 of the bandwidth it bleeds at least
95 of the bandwidth is the most colorful
way to die
right it's the not the most likely way
to die it's the most colorful way to die
and so I I think that all all media is
distorted and they're they're all edited
and they're all focused to a certain
agenda the only thing you can reasonably
do is you can scan a bunch of them you
can scan you know your own Twitter feed
will also be distorted so you have to
scan other feeds and then you have to be
continually going through this exercise
in your head of saying
that happened is it true
and then how significant is it for for
example
Argentine inflation 105 is it true no
Because the actual inflation rate is
higher it's it's indicative of a truth
how significant is it well how many
people live in Argentina that's one
level of significance the second is how
much money's in Argentina
and the third level significance is how
and you know how symbolic or or how how
indicative
or catalytic is it to other activity
that will happen the rest of the world
right how symbolic is it so you
I I think that
I'm in my 50s I'm 58.
if if everybody's worth by the way
February fourth same birthday is May
that's right if if you roll the clock
back and you read the the same newspaper
in your teens you'll interpret something
different if you read news in your 20s
it's different and your 30s it's
different in your 40s it's different
powerful when you get to your 50s if you
read the same like you read the same
history book and you're reading it in
your 50s like wow I totally interpreted
this differently when I was a ninth
grader right when I was in college I
interpreted this differently so you have
to have real world experience oftentimes
you'll read a story and they'll State
something and the truth is the exact
opposite of what the story is
but you have to have lived life like for
example you read a headline uh we found
500 Stone axes in a cave in Africa
they're between 1.2 and 1.7 million
years old
oh a school kid will say oh yeah so I
guess they found some Stone axes
I look at that and I say well there was
a factory that made Stone axes in Africa
1.7 million years ago that meant that
there was demand for thousands of stone
axes a year that meant that there was an
entire civilization that existed right
in fact there was money there was a
government there was a Furniture Factory
there was a clothing Factory there was a
there was agriculture there was an
entire Society you had to have 10 000
people all working together in
coordination to justify having an
inventory of 500 Stone axes
right and the only reason you actually
read about the stone axes is Stone ax is
the only thing that's going to last a
million years from now right and so what
was there was a thousand acts more
interesting the fact is there was an
interesting higher level civilization
with agriculture one and a half million
years ago they're not writing that in
the history book because the literal
historian only wants to report the bare
minimum but the reason that I could
actually tell you
thousand other things
is that I actually read books on
Austrian economics I you know I ran a
business I traded I saw the the Meltdown
and and the uh the creation of dozens of
of Industries
and I understand human nature
right and so if you understand you know
and you live the life you're like well
if I you know if I drink cartons of
orange juice every day for months in a
row I know what's going to happen to me
it's not good
you can reverse that right and you can
figure out what people ate a hundred
thousand years ago you know you they
they didn't do the things that we don't
really think are good ideas today
because they wouldn't appropriated
through a hundred thousand Generations
so I think that when you read the news
in your 50s if you've lived a life and
by the way like a lot of things I
interpret are because I ran a company
for 30 years
you know like for example you know like
a teenager yeah if you look at movies
created by people in their 20s they have
this view of business people like the
badass billionaire business guy walks in
and ever and he tells everybody what to
think and they you know and he's the you
know he's the evil Dr Evil Genius but if
you've actually run a business you know
I remember back last time I told
somebody what to think and they told me
to go f myself
right and then you know and you are
dressed in black you know you're and now
I have a meeting and and I'm very polite
you know like and the more talented you
are the more polite I am you know
because I realize that the world will go
on without me
like the those people think oh yeah well
I gotta work for the man well no you
don't I have 2 000 people in my company
right now I have hired 30 000 people
they don't have to work for the man
right the truth is unbelievable point
you know you hire people you realize
that they are they will quit if they
don't like the seal gets fired more
often than employees do yeah yeah I lost
27 500 employees all right so you you
think I take them for granted yeah
but but you have but I but I didn't when
I was 24 like what a perspective the
time when you are most confident when
you have the most amount of formal
education and the least amount of Real
World Experience like in your early 20s
right because you think you can do it
better than everybody else and you
haven't failed
and when you get another 25 years out
you're like oh I tried that that didn't
work I tried that that didn't work I
tried that that didn't work oh yeah that
was a really good employee but they quit
because I was rude to them oops I wish I
hadn't done that oops took that for
granted so I guess I'm coming back to
your question how what do I think about
the news it's like can you give us one
name one source like do you go to
something that's not the traditional one
everybody else goes to any person I know
it's not 100 accuracy you trust but give
us one sword no I I I think I think to
give a boost to Twitter and Elon Musk
the Boost is there are analysts and
there are domain experts on Twitter that
don't have corporations that don't have
lawyers to tell them they're not allowed
to say that thing and they actually say
the truth can you give us their names a
couple of them Michael I want to hold
you to give us one name no no give us
follow me on Twitter I mean you can look
at all
about 600 people okay so then follow the
people you're following they're they're
honest analysts and there are people
that are domain experts and they publish
their unadulterated thoughts and if you
actually put together a mosaic of all
those things with your own Real World
Experience you'll start to synthesize a
viewer of reality which is I think
probably more reliable than anyone you
know edited traditional media somebody
just gave a 500 Super Chat and ask this
question said have more people been
hacked owning Bitcoin then banks have
failed
Bitcoins never misses John coaster
bitcoin's never been hacked so the the
the only people that suffer with Bitcoin
are people that trust their Bitcoin to
the sand bankman Freeds of the world if
you put your Bitcoin in Celsius or block
Phi or FTX if you if you put it in an in
a wildcat bank and the bank steals your
money
right the the real message of bitcoiners
is don't trust verify and be your own
bank and not your keys not your coins so
the message of Bitcoin is you can't
trust anybody
if I if I actually told you the world is
made up of imperfect people and there
let's say there's a hundred families and
we all have money and none of us trust
each other and we all know we have idiot
kids that are going to take over the
family business and time and we want to
create a Community Bank where we can
collectively put our money the answer
would be well you don't put anybody in
charge of it you don't put any one
family in charge of it you know you
might be the smartest amongst us and
you're and your son's gonna have an
issue my son and eventually three
generations down the road is not going
to work anymore so you write a piece of
software everybody checks the software
we all agree the software is honest we
put the software on a computer nobody
trusts your computer we create a hundred
computers everybody runs their own
computer with the software we all agree
collectively not to change the software
and anybody that tries to change the
software gets kicked out of the network
that's what Bitcoin is it's it's an
honest approach to solve a problem when
you can't rely on a person you can't
rely on a family you can't rely on an
institution you can't rely on a
government what we rely on is the
collective self-interest of rational
people over time with regard to that one
thing and and it really is a beautiful
invention how Monumental would the
Bitcoin having be I think it's uh
expected in April of 2024 so in a little
less than a year how big of a deal is
that
I I think it's a catalyst to the upside
clearly I mean the amount of Bitcoin
that the miners receive in a reward they
might sell will be cut in half so
there's so that's a good thing but I I
would say that any rational person that
studied Bitcoin for 10 hours knows that
there will never be more than 21 million
Bitcoin and so you you know there's less
than that because some millions of
Bitcoin have been lost and they'll never
be spent
and so you're buying Bitcoin because you
know it's capped and you know the gold
and silver and oil and soybeans and
paper currency and land and apartments
are not capped everything else on Earth
is going to keep increasing in Supply
forever Bitcoin is not so once you
figure that out then the only question
is is there anything better and you sift
through the other 20 000 cryptos and if
they're not better and they're not
better then this is the one now every
intelligent person with money
has put their money on bitcoin so what
are you going to bet on you're going to
bet on the networks that were invested
in by people without money that aren't
intelligent right so so Bitcoin is the
winner because the smart money has
chosen it
there are a lot of other catalysts right
every time there's hyperinflation in a
place like Argentina it's a catalyst
every time a bank fails it's a catalyst
every time someone Builds an application
that's cool on bitcoin right like all
the ordinals and inscriptions and
whatever they're driving up transaction
fees it's Catalyst every time a company
like microstrategy buys another 100
million dollars worth of bitcoin it's
Catalyst every time a regulator actually
clarifies the fact that Bitcoin is a
commodity an asset without an issuer and
it's special
that's catalyst so lots of catalysts
they're all going to continue the result
will be Bitcoin will chop its way up
with volatility
forever just going to keep grinding up
because for you to believe Bitcoin is
going to grind up all you got to believe
is that human beings have a natural
tendency to want to to improve their
life and protect their property and and
and benefit their friends and family if
somebody gave 2 billion Zimbabwe dollars
that's actually 500. two nickels it's
actually 540 that they gave Michael
there you go can you give us your take
on ordinals txn fees on bitcoin or btcr
currently hired in any point in the last
three years and we are seeing uh use
cases like nfts on BTC main chain will
this shift developers from ethereum to
bitcoin is Sailor Pro or anti-ordinal
this is from an Assyrian brother ninos
and ninor so what are your thoughts on
this ah my boys okay so so Sailors Pro
freedom and pro markets and sailor
believe he's an Austrian Economist so
all value is subjectives here's what I
think I think everybody should be able
to launch whatever business they want to
launch and I think uh everybody should
be able to pursue pursue uh
their happiness however they want and
I think that lots of people will create
lots of things that won't work
so I'm not going to give you a
recommendation of stocks because some
businesses will work some won't and some
stocks will you will buy too high and
some you will not and I don't want to be
on the hook for 10 000 stocks I'm not
going to tell you how to gamble but I'm
not going to tell you not to I'm not
going to give you a recommendation for a
private business you want to collect art
you know I'm not going to tell you not
to I'm just not going to tell you which
piece of art to buy to make money I
don't know which which thing is going to
work and I know that over time
all all Fiat currencies will fail and
over time I believe most businesses in
fact all businesses will not be as good
as investing in Bitcoin because Bitcoin
is the low risk asset I do think that
what happened over the past five months
is pretty interesting if you go to New
Year's Eve
the average fee on the Bitcoin
blockchain was like three SATs per V
byte there were blocks every 10 minutes
that had six hundred dollars of
transaction fees in them right and so
the miners were getting a reward of a
hundred thousand dollars with six
hundred dollars or three hundred dollars
of fees so the fees were one percent of
the reward there were nothing de minimis
and and what happened over five months
is Bitcoin had a massive rally all of a
sudden the miners were getting a hundred
and fifty thousand dollar
or two hundred thousand dollar reward
but then we saw fees transaction fees
that got to more than six Bitcoin which
was a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars in fees so we went from a
thousand dollars in fees to a hundred
thousand dollars in fees a factor of a
hundred increase
and uh the fees started to approach
parity with the reward
if you're an investor in Bitcoin mining
if you're a Bitcoin miner and you want a
bullish thesis
in order to have a bullish thesis you
want to see that fees transaction fees
are at parity with rewards and you wanna
then you want to to have a a belief the
transaction fees will increase at a rate
faster than the hash rate
so if the hash rate's going up 20 a year
and transaction fees are going up 30
percent a year then that's a good
business a really good business and and
so in a world where transaction fees are
one percent that they're irrelevant you
don't have parity and then the growth
rate doesn't matter and then all you see
is the rewards are decreasing 18 a year
and that's a bearish scenario so I think
that what what happened with ordinals
and nfts is we cross this Chasm from
what was a bearish scenario to a bullish
scenario if I was a minor I would be
ecstatic I think that long term it there
are a lot of implications uh long term
the implication is there's going to be a
lot of applications on the Bitcoin base
layer yeah if I can inscribe a piece of
art right an nft is kind of an art but I
could also inscribe my last will and
testament and if my last will and
testament is moving a billion dollars
from me to you how much is it worth to
you to have that burned onto the
blockchain and cryptographically
verified yeah at least a billion dollars
for me what'd you pay 20 bucks yeah 100
yeah would you pay a hundred dollars of
course there you go so there are
interesting applications if I have a
corporate resolution to make a billion
dollar investment and I DocuSign it and
and I'm worried about getting sued for
hundreds of millions of dollars in the
future would I pay a hundred bucks to
burn that on the blockchain maybe
probably if I have a message I want to
send around the world and I don't want a
hostile nation state to to interfere
with that message is that worth 20 bucks
or 50 bucks sure it is so what people
are realizing is the transactions on the
blockchain they they are the ability to
send a message that a nation-state can't
stop their ability to put um to put a
document on on a network for a hundred
years that no one can actually tamper an
immutable blockchain
I mean if I can store a billion dollars
for a hundred years that's valuable but
you know if you had if you wanted to
move 10 million dollars of oil from New
York to London
it would cost you about three hundred
fifty thousand dollars
so what if I want to move 10 million
dollars of Bitcoin from New York to
London
what if I want to move 10 million
dollars worth of a document of something
of if you wanted to sell a 10 million
dollar work of art that's five hundred
thousand dollars to a million or more in
auction fees so so people have thought
well transactions man they
there's no future for them but I
actually am of the opinion that
transactions at a dollar or two dollars
transaction they're very undervalued
this is the most valuable most
tamper-proof immutable secure
transaction Network in the world
if I gave you a hundred billion dollars
and I said attack the network you
couldn't do it
if you were a nation with a hundred
billion dollars in four years you could
slow it down
but you couldn't stop it so I I think
that the real significance of ordinals
and nfts and inscriptions is people used
to take the transactions for for granted
and they undervalued the Bitcoin mining
Network and now I think what you have is
a lot of speculation and you also have
um you have a migration of crypto
development energy from the other
cryptos to bitcoin that's a good thing I
think it's in very it's it's inevitable
because Bitcoin is the low risk crypto
Network and the high security crypto
Network so so you're going to see
speculation move you're going to see
development move
but um but long term what's really
significant here is that people are
going to see Bitcoin as the most secure
Cyber Network of the most secure
computer network in the world
and if I told you I'm going to burn a
document and I want it to stay immutable
for a hundred years and I don't want any
hostile Corporation or nation state or
actor to be able to tamper with it or
stop it
and in a hundred years I want to prove
that that's my document
you know Satoshi could sign a digital
document he could sign a message today
and prove that he owns 30 billion
dollars of Bitcoin and he could do it in
a Split Second
that's the power of the Bitcoin Network
and that has been under realized it's uh
it's underestimated so I think that what
what's going to go right now is it's
going to be a lot of excitement but
ultimately the ethically sound
technically sound economically sound
future
is for people to realize that Bitcoin is
this immutable you know incorruptible
non-sovereign computer network and it's
going to protect your money but it's
also going to protect your integrity and
people are going to pay money for truth
on that Network and that's what's going
to finance those Miners and when you
look at all those miners running in
Texas you're saying what are they doing
they're protecting
the Integrity of Western Civilization
maybe of all the protecting the
Integrity of the human race for the next
thousand years that's worth something
that's powerful we got five minutes and
uh I want to go through two things with
you one you said the Satoshi uh how
often do you guys text each other are
you guys like in communication regularly
or is he
Satoshi every day really does he think
about you is there like a direct line of
community because you're becoming
gradually the Billy Graham of Bitcoin
like you know you went from a
non-believer to a Believer it was a
one-way gift
the reason that Bitcoin is ethical is
Satoshi made a one-way gift to the human
race asking nothing in return and and
that is an extraordinary wow as a guide
that you said you hired 30 000 employees
uh 2000 are still with you you've been
operating for 30 years okay you've been
a billionaire for a minute you were
billionaire in the late 90s and you've
been in that talks for you it's probably
not a big deal because you've been that
for a while but to to the average person
to see that category where there's only
700 to 900 of you in America it's a
pretty big deal to get to a place like
that there's a guy right now that could
be potentially looking for another job
and he was being interviewed on MSNBC by
this lady named Stephanie Rule and he
was asked the question I'm curious to
know if you would hire somebody like
this this is a phenomenal question here
there's not a Fortune 500 company in the
world looking to hire a CEO in his 80s
so why would an 82 year old Joe Biden be
the right person for the most important
job in the world because I have acquired
a hell of a lot of wisdom
and know more than the vast majority of
people are more experienced than
anybody's ever run through the office
I think I've proven myself to be
honorable as well as also effective
would you hire somebody like that to run
a I don't know like a
four or five trillion dollar year
company whatever the numbers 32 trillion
dollar company give or take I could be
off on the GDP
you think that would be a good co for a
company that size
it could be a question that's somewhere
above my pay grade I I I think that uh
wait wait you're a voter Tom let's see
what he's got to say I I think that the
number one criteria to run an
organization you know is
humility
combined with a bit of wisdom
from life experience but combined with
an extraordinary amount of of energy you
know you you have to eat sleep and breed
the thing
and I think that organizations that have
um that have people with too much
confidence they tend to go off the rails
and so it's it's good to know what you
don't know
got it so so to understand the what you
meant we have to speak sign language so
he left it to you guys you decide what
our Frontier meant by that whether you
but just just out for your own company
if you were looking to a point where you
would be replacing yourself as a CEO
would you look at somebody and value a
person with you know who's 82 years old
wanting to be the CEO microstrategy or
would you look for somebody younger or
would it even matter to you age-wise
well I mean I did have the opportunity
to replace myself last year and I'm the
executive chairman and we're we
appointed a new CEO and the CEO is Fong
Lee and and he's um
in his 90s he's in his 40s okay early
40s so you weren't like you weren't
going on like senior ceos.com and
looking for recruiters to to find like I
mean that's not even seniors right
because baby boomers what 1946 to 64. so
you weren't interested in experience
and I'm I'm not going to say the perfect
age to be CEO because there are a lot of
examples I mean I I myself appointed
myself CEO at age 24 but then again I
was only responsible for myself
and I couldn't mess much up because I
inherited you know and it took me many
many years to get to the point where I
could break something
well I think that the bigger the
organization the more careful one needs
to be this is a pretty big organization
we're talking about and this guy's
applying for that job 300 million anyway
so uh Michael every time you come uh by
the time you're done talking my brain
feels like has had a four hour workout
even though it was only 90 minutes today
because you make me think and I love the
way you explain and you're always
gathering information from different
places and the audience loves this so
this is a I think you're one of only uh
three or four names that we've had on
three times so if you've never felt like
maybe if you recently have not been
getting enough love we just want to make
sure you know we love Michael Saylor the
Billy Graham of Bitcoin that's going to
be the new nickname by the way the
Evangelist the Evangelist the Billy
Graham of Bitcoin baptizing folks in
Bitcoin around the world okay if you
don't remember anything else I said
today just remember Bitcoin is Hope
and go to hope.com that's where all the
information is really is Bitcoin good
laser eyes Bitcoin good you can boil it
all down to that everything else is
complicated and big week next week the
Miami Bitcoin uh conference is going to
be yeah 15
000 cyber Hornets coming to Miami no
I'll be right here it's gonna be awesome
you're gonna baptize all of them and
name the Satoshi and what would be the
third you know there's got to be the
technology right anyways Michael once
again thank you gang all this stuff is
below links Rob let's put it there for
people to be able to find the uh Michael
I asked him a question earlier about
Michael who do you follow on uh social
what you read their articles if you go
follow his Twitter account you'll be
able to know who he follows and that's
where you'll see where he gets his Intel
from okay maybe that's one way to find
out where uh who those 590 people are
that Mr sailor follows anyways gang
we're about to announce the next live
podcast if you want to be one of the
first to know about a text award podcast
to 3103 four zero one one three two
again three one zero three four zero one
one three two text award podcast thank
you everybody bye-bye bye-bye